lo muere
todo
siguen pidiendo
[Música]
cuándo
lima
[Música]
o no
lima
[Música]
longo
sin envidia
cuando la alegría
[Música]
alejandra a temblar artista muchísimas
gracias bienvenida un placer tenerte con
nosotros aquí en radio canadá
internacional
muchas gracias por invitarme alejandra
tú estás preparando un espectáculo que
se llama los niños son inocentes número
uno
explícanos en qué consiste este
espectáculo en qué consiste este
espectáculo y quiénes te acompañan
te dejo el micrófono vale ese
espectáculo es un espectáculo
pluridisciplinario así se dicen en el
que juntamos teatro con flamenco cante
flamenco
bueno hay más allá del cante también
armonía y ritmos flamencos jazz y
electrónica es decir está la de la
guitarra eléctrica y también este
samples programación
e
es un espectáculo que sigue una trama
narrativa
planteamos la la cuestión de la
confianza en
en quien podemos confiar hoy en día
donde podemos encontrar una palabra en
la que podamos confiar
y más allá de eso
donde podemos recuperar nuestra propia
confianza ha visto el panorama
sintiéndonos siempre tan impotentes y
tan desesperados
cómo podemos recuperar esa confianza y
por lo tanto nuestro poder de acción
individual
si quieres te acompañan en tu
espectáculo y en este espectáculo tengo
la grandísima suerte de contar con un
equipo maravilloso el el apoyo principal
es hugo la arena que es guitarrista
trabajé mucho la base del espectáculo
con él luego se juntaron este
sebastián pero al contrabajo él es de
jazz david reich van al al piano y a la
programación también él es también de
jazz y miguel medina a la percusión
miguel toca mucho en el ámbito flamenco
tú dices que este espectáculo es un
diálogo musical entre la modernidad y la
tradición como se establece ese diálogo
y ese diálogo yo lo veo en que el
flamenco es un arte excesivamente
complejo
que requieren muchos respetos yo le
tengo muchísimo respeto al flamenco
entonces fui a españa a aprenderlo es un
aprendizaje de una vida o hasta varias o
sea que uno está constantemente
aprendiendo
pero ni siquiera dos yo creo que ellas
se necesitan más este entonces eso es
una tradición muy fuerte no
y mi intención es obviamente respetar la
esencia de esa tradición
pero sin encerrarme en ella tampoco
porque yo no soy flamenca y no pretendo
ser flamenca lo uso como un idioma lo
voy mezclando con también mi bagaje
lírico mi bagaje de teatro mi bagaje de
filosofía y lo voy mezclando todo en una
propuesta contemporánea en el sentido de
que procuro que la estética le llegue a
la gente porque lo que lo que me importa
más que cualquier forma es el la
historia no entonces con ese afán de
decir algo concreto a la gente voy
montando una forma y ese algo concreto
que quiero contar es un tema
profundamente actual o sea quiero hablar
de cosas de ahora a la gente de ahora
tú hablas de la gente alejandra cuál es
el mensaje finalmente cuál es el mensaje
que tú quieres que la gente retenga de
tu espectáculo
el mensaje que ojalá consiga transmitir
y no solo en ese espectáculo sino en
toda toda mi carrera artística es
que la belleza existe
la belleza existe
no es un
una opinión individual singular o sea
hay una objetividad de la belleza y en
esa belleza hay un conocimiento y un
conocimiento muy profundo sobre el ser
humano
lo que intento transmitir es que el ser
humano tiene sentido
el ser humano
la existencia del ser humano tiene un
propósito
y ese propósito es bello
y la vida tiene sentido no solo merece
la pena sino que tiene sentido entonces
ese sentido lo veo en cuando uno se
siente relacionado con los demás cuando
somos un nosotros con mayúscula
y eso es lo que procuro transmitir y a
nivel físico lo que se siente en esos
momentos es alegría recuperar esa
alegría que nos hace falta en esa
sociedad lo tenemos todo y no no somos
felices realmente falta mucha alegría en
la vida diaria en las relaciones yo noto
que se si falta
hay una necesidad de alegría la alegría
es la vida necesitamos más vida estoy
totalmente de acuerdo contigo
necesitamos alegría te gustaría agregar
algo en particular muy rápidamente antes
de terminar esta entrevista
este no yo creo que solo para resumir el
espectáculo o para resumir más que el
espectáculo toda mi intención como
artista alguien dijo que después de
haber visto el espectáculo que era una
experiencia este religiosa aconfesional
lo puso en inglés no dijo en donde
nóminas yo no leyes experience y me
pareció que era una manera muy justa de
resumir mi intención como artista eso es
lo que procuro cuando me subo al
escenario procuro que suceda algo que se
puede aparentar a eso una experiencia
religiosa aconfesional
un sentirse relacionados en un
consentido sentir que estamos
relacionados y que hay sentido
alejandra templier muchísimas gracias
por esta entrevista a radio canadá
internacional muchas gracias
[Música]